- I saw in the news today
talking about the violence
in foreign countries.
Talking about all the
savagery up in the world.
But they ain't never
talk about South Central.
Ain't never talk about what
happened to my brother.
Now he's gone.
Now I ain't got no brother.
- Yo dog.
I'll be your brother.
- Really?
- Absolutely, dog.
You're gonna need
somebody to lean on.
You can't just be
walking around here
with this emptiness
in your heart, man.
An emptiness that can only
be filled by a brother.
(sniffling)
- Okay.
- Brothers, man?
- Brothers.
- Let's get it in there, dog.
- [Peele] Come over here.
- You gotta get
it in there, dog.
- [Peele] You
gotta tuck it, man.
Tuck it, tuck it, tuck
it, tuck it, tuck it.
- Brothers, man.
- [Key] Come here, man.
Why the (bleep) you keep
following me around, man?
Why don't you go home
and stay outta my room?
No, man. Don't mess
with my models.
I'm about to get a wedgie in
this mother (bleep) right here.
- [Peele] What the (bleep)
Hey. Hey, come on. Get
the (bleep) off me, man.
- Give me the wedgie. Hey.
- Hey, you don't give
a grown man a wedgie.
(clears throat)
Mother (bleep),
I'm 34 years old.
(beatboxing)
(yelling and searing)
(laughs maniacally)
- Omega Pi Omega!
(hooting)
- Yeah!
- Yo, brand me, son. Brand me.
Do it on my chest. Straight
down the middle, son.
- [Key] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(searing and both yelling)
Yeaaah, son!
- Oh, yo, yo. Yo, hold
up man. Come on, wait.
- [Peele] Wait, wait. That
(bleep) upside down, son.
It's to the side
a little bit, too.
- Oh, (bleep). My
bad, dog. My bad dog.
You wanna keep doing
this (bleep). Let's go!
- Yeah, man.
I'm just, I'm saying
yo, be careful.
- I got you, dog. I got you.
(searing and both yelling)
- [Key] What's up?
That's what's up!
Straight down the middle, son.
- You can't go back
middle now, son.
- What?!
- We already committed
to the upside down
and to the side.
- I got you, dog!
(searing and both yelling)
- What are you doing, man?
- You said upside
down and to the side.
- That's three omegas!
- Oh man, I forgot the pi.
(searing and both yelling)
- [Peele] Oh.
- Oh man. I mean, you
know that like, that man,
that, that could
be a rocket ship.
- [Key] Or, or a lighthouse.
Nah, man. You straight up
got a (bleep) on your chest.
(yelling)
- To the man of the hour.
- [Man In Gray Shirt] Guys,
best bachelor party ever.
(all cheering)
- Oh yeah. That's the
stuff. I can still do it.
- All right, fellas.
What do you say
we get a stripper.
- [All] Yes!
- Trey, I told you,
man, no strippers.
- Is this a bachelor
party or isn't it?
- [Trey] That's what I'm saying.
I'm your best man.
There's no way I'm
gonna let you puss out
on your own bachelor party.
- [Trey] We gettin''
the stripper
and we gonna connect the dots.
- Yes!
- Connect the dots?
- Yeah. Tinker toy it, man.
You're behind her
and then we all
buh-buh-buh-bup.
We go to town.
- Yeah!
- To town!
- Wait, wait, hold
on, hold on. Wait.
What's, what's, what's
"buh-buh-buh-bup"?
- [Trey] Dude, you know,
you're up front then...
buh-buh-buh-bup. Game on!
(laughing)
- Game on.
- Guys, hold up, hold up.
- [Tommy] Hold up, hold up.
No, what's the "ba-ba-ba-bup".
- Yeah, what is that?
- Guys. This is Tommy's last
night of freedom. Come on!
- What's
"buh-buh-buh-bup" though?
- You know! buh-buh-buh-bup!.
- [Man With Gray Shirt]
Okay, okay, okay.
When you say "buh-buh-buh-bup",
are we, what are we?
Are we all...?
- Linked up! Yeah! Baby
elephant walk. Woo!
- Okay, okay, okay, um.
Are... are you saying
that, that we would,
we would all be
(bleep) each other?
- Dude, you don't
understand what I'm say...
- [Trey] Oh, dude. Okay.
Look. Here it is, okay?
You're (bleep) girl, right?
(all agreeing)
Then we buh-buh-buh-bup.
- No, that's it right
there. Right there.
- Yeah. Yeah. What the
(bleep). I'm not doing that.
- You guys!
- [Trey] Tommy's about to
walk the plank of marriage,
all right?
This is our last chance.
- Last chance for what? I'm
not gonna (bleep) a guy.
- No, dude!
We'd all be (bleep) the girl.
- [All] Oh, okay!
- Together! Buh-buh-buh-bup.
- [All] No!
- See, but right there,
that's the weird part.
The buh-buh-buh-bup!
- Okay. I get it. I get it.
You don't wanna be disrespectful
to women. I get that.
- That that's really the issue.
- Forget the girl.
Armenian conveyor belt.
Just the groom
and his groomsman.
Buh-buh-buh-bup.
- [All] No!
- You kept the part
that nobody wants!
The buh-buh-buh-bup!
- Yeah. I definitely
don't wanna have sex
with any of you guys.
- Yeah, you're killing my buzz!
- [Trey] Guys! What
the (bleep) man?
This is supposed to be
Tommy's last big celebration.
No judgment!
- Judgment is not
what is keeping us
from (bleep) each other.
Geez. Forget it, Trey.
- No, I'm saying guys if
you listen to my words,
Tommy's in here
(bleep) the stripper.
We're in the other room.
Buh-buh-buh-bup.
- [All] No!
- Nobody wants the
buh-buh-buh-bup!
- Okay, fine! No
Okay? No buh-buh-buh-bup!
You're here, (bleep)
the stripper.
The rest of us are just
Jiggy jiggy jiggy jiggy jiggy.
- [All] No!
- Oh my, God. You
guys are so gay!
(rustling and panting)
(snapping)
- (whispering) Bro.
- What?
- (mouthing) Look
me in the eyes.
Lock 'em.
- [Peele] Lock' em. Yeah.
(bleep) yeah, bro.
How awesome is this?
- It's cool.
- (bleep) yeah it is.
Hit it, hit it, hit it.
- [Peele] Hit it. Yeah.
Dude, synchronize, synchronize.
- [Peele] There. Now we're
doing it. Now we're doing it.
Now we're doing it.
- [Peele] Doing it with my bro.
Doing it with my bro.
I love every second I'm
doing it with my bro.
- It's, it's pretty awesome.
- Can you believe it?
- I, I'm... Can you just.
- Yo, yo. Right there,
man. Just give me five.
- [Peele] Give me five, bro.
That's (bleep) pussy
(bleep). Come on.
- [Peele] Come on.
Oh, you're with me now.
You are with me.
- That's disturbing.
- Keep 'em locked.
Keep 'em locked.
- [Peele] You ain't going
nowhere. Give me five.
- Nuh-uh.
- Give it back.
- Get the...
Oh!
Oh, jeez.
- Dude, how we gonna
break the world record
if you can't keep it up.
- It is so good
to see you, Keith.
- Yeah, we usually have to
wait for a special case.
- Well, actually I
have a little surprise.
I got engaged.
- Oh!
(excited laughter)
- Oh, son.
(slow clapping)
- [Clive] Woo hoo.
Yes. Wow.
Congratulations, little bro.
Engaged. Kind of a big deal.
More for me, I guess.
That's what that means.
- [Dad] Yes. Well,
she got a name?
- Stephanie.
- Marriage is a
wonderful journey.
- [Clive] 50% end in
divorce. Sorry, bro.
Them's just the facts.
- [Keith] I will, I will
keep that in mind. Thank you.
- You got a photo?
- Oh, yeah.
- AKA: Does she exist?
- There you go.
(whistles)
- Mmm. Haha.
- Oh, she's beautiful.
- Don't...
- [Clive] Let me
get eyes on this.
Everybody else already ha...
Great lighting.
Airbrushed?
- No.
- She kind of looks
like that one model
on The Price Is Right.
- Yes. That's her.
- The Price is Right.
Clive, that's your show.
- Shut up, mom!
- [Clive] No, it's not.
Oh, yeah.
Stephanie.
- Mhm.
- [Clive] People always
underbid on her showcases.
Not the best presenter.
- Where's the wedding?
- Oh! In Hawaii.
- Oh!
- [Clive] Oh-ho-ho-ho!
(clapping)
Awesome.
(cheering)
Mele Kalikimaka.
She ever been married before?
- No.
- So she says.
Ex-boyfriends, she got one?
- Of course.
- Sloppy seconds, at least.
Right, Dad?
- Keith, she sounds wonderful.
- [Keith] Thank you, Mom.
- Shut up, Mom!
- [Clive] Silence from you.
You're cut off from talking.
- You know what, Clive?
I really don't
appreciate the way
that you're talking to Mom.
(clapping and laughing
sarcastically)
- Yes. Yes.
The prodigal son hath returned.
- [Clive] You know
what? You wanna go?
Let's go.
'Cause I've been here
for the last 15 years
taking care of Mom and Dad.
While you've been trollopsing
all over the world and why?
So you can come back
here and criticize me
for how I treat them?
- No.
I actually came here to ask you
if you would do me the honor
of being my best man.
- Oh.
(snorts)
- [Keith] I know that we
have had our differences,
but you're my older brother.
(snorts)
- We'll pay for your room.
- [Keith] And we're also
gonna rent you a car.
And we'll pay to
fly you out there.
- First class.
- Well, we, we can't
afford first class.
- Well, (bleep) you.
You're dead to me.
- [Mom] Why?
- [Clive] Shut up, mom!
I'm eating in my room.
- Well, that, that went
better than expected.
- I think so.
- Yeah.
- Man, I felt sorry
for that dude,
but you know what you gonna do?
I had to lay that (bleep) down.
(laughing)
- What? That (bleep)
lay you down.
- Hey, brother. I don't
know what fight you was at.
That (bleep) got a couple
licks in, sure, but
(blows raspberry)
But I was like: Bip!
Man, I put the pussy
on the chainwax.
(laughing)
- [Key] Put the pussy...
- [All] On the chainwax.
- Put the pussy...
- [Key] Put the pussy...
- [All] On the chainwax.
- Pussy on the chainwax?
Is that a thing?
- Well, yeah, that, yeah,
that's a, that's a thing.
- Yeah.
- That's something.
- Okay.
- Yeah. I put the on
pussy on the chainwax.
- [All] Pussy on the chainwax!
(all talking over each other)
- Hold up.
- [Brody] Hold up.
I just Googled pussy on
the chainwax. No results.
- Man, why are you Googling?
- No, I'm just saying.
Pussy on the chainwax.
It's not an expression.
- Yeah, it is.
- Yes, thank you, Leo.
- It's something.
- What, what, what
does it mean then?
- What does it mean?
I'll tell you what it means.
It means...
That...
Is that you put the
pussy on the chainwax.
(shouting)
- Nope.
- Pussy on the chainwax!
- It's not, no.
- Pussy on the chainwax.
- Acting like y'all
know what it is.
Okay. Have either
the two of you,
have you ever said the words
pussy on the chainwax
in any context?
- Us?
- He talking me, man.
He ain't talking to me.
- Hey man, it's not our fault
that you ain't never put
the pussy on the chainwax.
Pussy on the chain wax!
- No one can put the
pussy on the chain wax
'cause on the chainwax
ain't a thing.
You trying to start
a thing, aren't you?
- What?
I mean, what are
you talking about?
Trying to start a thing.
- A thing like off the hook
or I'm gonna put you on blast.
You trying to get
it in the ether,
so everybody out there
saying pussy on the chainwax.
- Man, why you doing this?
Why you looking up
(bleep) I'm saying,
and, and fact checking
my ass and (bleep).
- You keep saying some
(bleep) that doesn't exist
and you got thing
one and thing two
corroborating your
story like it does.
And you, why you lying then?
It's bull (bleep)!
- Brody.
- Why do you care so much?
Whether I made up
pussy on the chainwax or not,
I lost my job.
My girl left me.
And all I, all I wanted to do.
Was have a little bit of fun
with my friends today.
So why? Why do you have...
Why do you have to
belittle me like that?
- It's just that I...
- Yeah?
- I'm just trying to say...
- What you trying
to say, (bleep)?
- I'm trying to say that
I want to put the pussy
- [All] On the chainwax!
(yelling in excitement)
- He did that!
- [All] He put the pussy
on the chainwax! Yeah!
- [Gogo] Roommate meeting.
Roommate. Meeting.
- Gogo, what the hell?
I've got a hangover.
- [Gogo] I don't give a
(bleep) about your hangover.
Okay, Brendan?
I want a roommate
meeting. I want it now.
Okay. Now somebody's
been taking (bleep)
out of the refrigerator and
throwing it on the ground
and it's pissing me off.
Is this another one of your
stupid pranks, Johnald?
- No. And your
pranks are stupid.
- Is it you, Monday?
- What?
- I said, somebody's
been taking (bleep)
out the fridge and throwing
it on the (bleep) ground
and I wanna know who it
is because it's not funny!
- Well, what I wanna
know is who keeps pulling
the sheets off my
bed and hanging them
from the ceiling fan at night.
- Was that you, Monday?
- What?
- Have you been taking
everybody's sheets
off in the night
and hanging 'em from
the ceiling fans.
- What? No.
- Well, clearly someone's
been doing that.
(glass shattering)
- Whoa. Who did that?
- Yeah. Who the
(bleep) did that?
- Which one are you
just threw that bottle?
- What are we even
talking about right now?
- Did you (bleep) throw
that bottle Johnald?
- No, Gogo. (bleep) you!
I didn't throw it.
- Well, did you (bleep)
throw that bottle, Brendan?
- Yeah! You would
do that, Brendan.
- Dude. No, I didn't
throw the bottle.
- Well, somebody threw
that (bleep) bottle
and you're the one who drew
dicks on everyone's foreheads!
- Yeah, you did do that!
- But dicks are
hilarious though!
This is just destructive.
What about you, Monday?
Did you throw that bottle?
- What bottle?
- The (bleep) bottle, dude.
It just smashed
against the wall.
And you even said
some (bleep) about it?
- Well, I didn't throw a bottle.
- Well, obviously
it wasn't Ping.
He's got the best
grades in the house.
(guttural scream)
- Good point,
Ping. Come on guys.
Let's cool it with
the profanity.
You know Ping's very religious.
(flies buzzing)
- [All] Aww, Ping!
(Outro music)